The joe rogan experience,
but now when I sit down and I cook something for my family,
I know where that came from.
If we have vegetables that we grow in our garden,
this is a great satisfaction for serving up some cucumbers or some,
some Kale or whatever it is that we grew in.
Our garden tastes better when you,
when you go out there and you cut that cucumber off the planet and you cut that
Kale down,
it is like half an hour old.
Like nothing compares to that freshness that you go to the grocery store that
may be a couple of days a week,
a month old.
You have no idea.
And for me as a chef,
um,
that's why I love hunting and foraging and having a garden in my backyard
because when you go and pick something,
nothing tastes as good as that.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean I appreciate where vegans and animal rights activists are coming from
because it's coming from,
I think there was,
there's a lot of distortion,
um,
with like really angry ones and,
but this is my take on a lot of this is you get a group of a hundred people,
one of them for sure is a fucking idiot.
Just out of just sheer odds,
right?
Like what are the odds?
One of them is a fucking,
it's pretty strong,
right?
Well,
if you're going to get a group of 100 vegans,
you're going to get at least one of them.
That's a fucking idiot.
And they're going to be,
some of them are violent.
Some of them were super aggressive about it.
I mean,
there's a ton of them online.
You can go,
they,
their identity is completely wrapped around veganism.
These vegan in their name,
it's always,
I'm the Vegan this or the Vegan that that is 100% of their name.
So 100% of their identity.
So they can't,
they can't separate from it ever.
Like that is who they are forever.
And they have,
there's been some serious problems.
What was the name of that cafe again?
Cafe gratitude.
Um,
there were some people that were running a Vegan restaurant.
I think they have a couple of them right in la.
And um,
they were having health issues and some people,
the Vegan Diet just doesn't agree with them.
And maybe they were doing it wrong.
Maybe they have unique dietary needs,
but they started raising cattle and they started eating those cattle and the
fucking vegans freaked out.
Death threats,
all this crazy shit coming after them protesting.
And you know,
these people were terrified.
They're older folks.
They're,
they're,
you know,
they're elderly.
They're,
it is Vegan restaurant owners received death threats over animal slaughter
scandal.
Yeah.
I mean this is the bad ones.
Right.
And it's not,
most of them,
most vegans I think,
are vegans for all the right reasons.
Yeah.
And if you are misinformed,
if you choose to,
to not,
uh,
to not eat meat and choose that kind of lifestyle,
like power too,
that's a too,
it's amazing.
And I think that,
you know,
if,
if it works for you and your body,
that's great.
And for me,
it doesn't work for me.
Like I,
I've,
I've done Vegan cleanses,
I've done the juice cleanses.
I've,
I've done,
you know,
I've gone out for,
as a chef to Vegan restaurants and I'm not full,
you know,
I'll,
I'll eat three or four courses,
I'll spend tons of money and half an hour later I'm starving,
starving.
And it's,
I just,
I need eat something with protein and lots of protein and it's,
it's meat or fish or,
you know,
uh,
I've made tofu from scratch,
from soybeans and it's just,
it doesn't,
it's not the same.
Yeah.
Well,
right now people are screaming at there,
you're doing it wrong.
My vegan food is,
I love it.
It's tasty,
but I'm not,
some of it is,
some of it's good.
I mean,
I eat vegan raw all the time.
There's a Vegan restaurant near me.
I go to all the time.
Sometimes you get dirty looks,
this motherfucker's here.
Why are you here and why you're not allowed to eat.
You're not one of us.
You're not allowed to eat our food.
Um,
it's just,
it's very unfortunate that I think these,
uh,
ideological groups get tainted by the most extreme members.
And I think that's true on the hunting side too.
And you got guys like fucking Ted Nugent,
you know,
and all the people that I think that they distort the,
the real
sort of fascinating and mystical qualities of wildlife and harvesting wildlife
and being out there and,
and experiencing nature.
It's an,
it's an almost psychedelic experience to,
to,
to hunt and be in the wild.
And that sounds so counterintuitive to someone who's never experienced it.
But the world of these animals,
when you are away from your cell phone,
when you're away from,
you know,
television and all the bullshit and the computer,
when you're,
when you're out there in the wild,
you are almost in another dimension.
If you are in complete silence in the forest and you,
your mind goes into a completely different sort of mode that is familiar but yet
alien,
it's familiar in a way that your body is like,
oh,
this is hunting.
This is what humans have done for hundreds of thousands of years.
This is why we became human.
I mean,
this is literally one of the reasons that scientists believed that our brains
grew is because we started eating meat,
we started cooking meat,
the nutrition became more accessible.
And also we started thinking about how to hunt,
developing tools to hunt with.
I mean all of this is the reason why humans are humans today.
And I'm sure the Vegan argument against that would be,
well,
that's then,
and we're past that now.
While we're not,
no,
we're not.
We're not.
Because of controlling the population of animals,
we're certainly not because of controlling the population of predators.
And that's another thing that people need to accept and understand.
There's a reason why they eradicated all the wolves in North America before they
reintroduced them to Yellowstone and now they're thriving.
And many parts of the northwest,
it's because they were fucking killing everything.
And there's,
they don't have any predators.
And the only predators that they have are humans.
And if we don't keep the populations in check of them and have grizzly bears
have black bears and all the other predators,
they start eating each other.
They start tearing each other apart.
They start coming after us.
They start encroaching on p well,
we're in their territory.
We shouldn't be in their place.
We humans.
Well,
look,
I'm on team people,
so I don't know what the fuck you're saying here.
If you're saying that we should move out of San Francisco and give it to the
wolves,
you can go fuck yourself.
All right?
And this is literally what it boils down to because you have to draw some line
in the sand somewhere because if someone doesn't control the population of
animals,
then what's going to happen?
Well,
you can leave them to their own devices and they can sort of sort it out,
but you know how they sorted out through disease and starvation.
I mean,
what happens is there's too many animals and not enough food.
So they get horrific diseases.
That's where mange comes from.
That's where a lot of like serious diseases that infect wildlife come from.
They come from a lack of food or overpopulation.
That's how nature sorts it out,
you know?
And that's how nature sorts of that with people too.
We're just sneaky.
We've used vaccines and shit and we're at the top of the food chain,
but we are,
we've worked hard to get there.
We are.
And I think we,
it comes with a certain responsibility and that responsibility is really,
we were really doing a disservice to that responsibility with factory farming.
And that's the one of the main arguments for veganism.
The one of the main arguments is the horrific treatment of those animals,
whether it's veganism or or,
or,
or whether it's weather factory farming or whether it's a large scale dairy
farms where they mistreat their cows or the chicken farms are all these
different factory farms where they treat these animals not as a living being,
but as a commodity.
Then it becomes a giant problem.
But if you look at guys like,
do you know Joel Salitan is no,
Joel Salitan is a very fascinating guy.
He runs a farm called Polyface farms and what he has essentially done is made
large scale animal agriculture possible in a humane and very natural way.
He has enormous electric fences that he uses for his pigs and he just moves them
around,
moves the fences around.
So the pigs wander around his a huge rolling chicken coop.
I mean,
it's fucking huge.
And he pushes that thing around.
He moves it to a new space,
the chickens go out,
they wander around and blah,
blah,
blah.
They do the chicken thing and they go right back into the chicken house and this
is where it gets the eggs from.
This is how they raise chickens.
This is how they raise cattle,
does that,
they do it with all these different animals.
And His perspective on all this is that if you've,
if you do it right,
it's not horrific.
It's not an evil thing.
And that these animals are living the way they've,
they're,
they're meant to live.
Right.
That's one.
That's one of the things that we do at Antler is t is to find those farmers and
guys like that.
One of the farms we get our deer from,
they have thousand acres.
The deer roam as they pleased.
They're eating nuts and apples and acorns and grass and everything they're
supposed to eat.
Uh,
and then when it's time,
they're,
they're collected and harvested.
And that,
that is where we get our meat from.
And we try really hard not to buy from these facts.
We don't serve chicken,
beef,
or pork.
We have bison pheasant duck a wellbore because,
you know,
these game farms,
they don't have these massive,
large scale operations and eye buy direct from the farmer.
And they can tell me what their diet is,
you know,
uh,
would,
they're good months,
they're bad months.
We know all about these animals that we're bringing to the restaurant.
And,
um,
and,
you know,
we're really proud of that.
Okay.